-Making their TV debut
performing "Never Freestyle"
and "Legacy" from their album,
"Apt. 505,"
give it up for Coast Contra.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-All: ♪ Whoa, whoa, whoa ♪
♪ You rockin' with the Coast
on "The Tonight Show" ♪
-♪ OK, I kick off, flip it ♪
-♪ Keep it movin' ♪
♪ Hip hop, you can't stop
this type of movement ♪
♪ I'm a story teller,
so let me get right into it ♪
♪ About this time,
I almost died over some booty ♪
-♪ Say what? ♪
-♪ Brown skin,
it was this cutie ♪
-♪ She threw a party at her
crib, told me come through but ♪
-♪ Dammit, I knew better,
granted, I'm too clever ♪
-♪ But I'm from Philly,
I'm ready rumble like whoever ♪
♪ I'm on the way, something kept
telling me boy you foolish ♪
♪ Couldn't get a lift from
my brotha, so called a Uber ♪
♪ Got dropped off, hit 5 five
stars, he was the coolest ♪
♪ But not the cleanest, but at
least he played my music ♪
♪ Huh, huh ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Huh, huh, huh ♪
♪ They offer poison and power ♪
♪ They offer Gucci and fame ♪
♪ They think I'm new
to this money ♪
to this game ♪
♪ They wanna see us in whips ♪
♪ They wanna see us in chains ♪
Legacy, legacy, legacy ♪
♪ They tryna ruin the name ♪
♪ Legacy, legacy, legacy, uh ♪
♪ They tryna ruin the name, uh ♪
♪ They offer poison and power,
uh ♪
♪ They offer Gucci and fame,
♪ Legacy, legacy, legacy, uh ♪
♪ Make 'em remember the name ♪
-♪ Phase one we was unfazed ♪
♪ Ain't no backlash
for the free slave ♪
♪ Ancestors plotting
in their graves ♪
♪ So the whips, chains
come custom made ♪
♪ Picking cotton
under sun rays ♪
♪ They were sweating bullets
under 12 gage ♪
-♪ Brrr ♪
-♪ Plantation turned
to shooting rage ♪
-♪ Slave masters
all in shooting range ♪
♪ Live a legend, I'm-a die
a legend with my honor ♪
♪ Doing this like when you spit
like this nice, homie ♪
-♪ You escape karma ♪
-♪ Me and my brothers is...♪
-♪ Some real rhymers ♪
♪ I'd say the greatest
is Coast Contra, it might be ♪
♪ Living legend, yeah,
I might be ♪
♪ Ahead of the game,
♪ Wait ♪
-♪ Wake up, blessed up ♪
-♪ Uh ♪
-♪ Hopped out, dripped up ♪
-♪ Paid dues, time's up ♪
-♪ Uh ♪
-♪ Body bag zipped up ♪
-♪ Rap God, prayed up ♪
-♪ Uh ♪
-♪ Long nights, stayed up ♪
-♪ Whole squad came up ♪
-♪ Uh ♪
-♪ Hip hop saved us ♪
♪ This the legacy,
this the life I chose ♪
♪ 505 we slept inside the cold ♪
-♪ Cold ♪
♪ Had to learn to cook
without the stove ♪
♪ Only thing that kept us hot
was flows ♪
♪ All my day 1's
A1 Honor Roll ♪
♪ We never ever disrespect
the code ♪
♪ Taj, Ras, Austin, Rio, Loz ♪
♪ Went from scrapping toast and
now we toast ♪
♪ Pulling women bad
as Amber Rose ♪
♪ The type of girls
ain't scared to be some ♪
♪ They drop us 50 just to pack
a show ♪
♪ We ballin now and I ain't
talking Rose ♪
♪ My Grammy told me don't you
sell your soul ♪
♪ Cause what's a Grammy when
your soul is gold ♪
♪ My only goal is I'm-a die
a G.O.A.T. ♪
♪ Cause this the lucky life
that I done chose ♪
-♪ They offer poison and power ♪
-♪ What? ♪
♪ They offer Gucci and fame ♪
♪ They think I'm new
to this money ♪
to this game ♪
♪ They wanna see us in whips ♪
♪ They wanna see us in chains ♪
♪ Legacy, legacy, legacy ♪
♪ They tryna ruin the name ♪
-♪ Let's go ♪
-♪ Legacy, legacy, legacy ♪
-♪ Uh! ♪
♪ They tryna ruin the name ♪
-♪ Uh ♪
-♪ Legacy, legacy, legacy ♪
-♪ They tryna ruin the name ♪
-♪ Uh ♪
-♪ They offer poison and power ♪
-♪ They offer Gucci and fame ♪
-♪ Uh ♪
-♪ Legacy, legacy, legacy ♪
♪ Make 'em remember the name ♪
-♪ My family gon' have power
like the Medicis ♪
♪ I feel like Fransisco Vitori ♪
-♪ Si! ♪
♪ Diplomatic since the attic ♪
♪ Writing bars brighter
than ya Patek, boy!
♪ They gon' hall of fame me
for my story ♪
♪ Critics turning
into crickets ♪
♪ Cause I'm just too big for any
category ♪
♪ And I planned it since
a lil boy ♪
♪ My flow drip
from a coca leaf ♪
♪ They ain't seen a brotha come
from overseas ♪
♪ I ain't talking Chanel but
it's luxury ♪
♪ Down in Colombia,
adonde yo naci ♪
♪ My legacy really the recipe ♪
-♪ Uh ♪
-♪ Mixing cultures now they
can't ignore it ♪
♪ Funny fake people saying that
they saw it ♪
♪ When I posted up a show they
wasn't going ♪
♪ Now they trick tryna come
with me on tour ♪
♪ I kicked the devil out ♪
♪ Mixing my sins with the weed
just to level out ♪
♪ Found me a better route ♪
♪ Rapping bout nothin' ain't
nothing to sing about ♪
-♪ Smoke ♪
-♪ Got the coast tatted in ink ♪
♪ Blood Coast Contra,
listen, my click is up ♪
♪ From birds on the curve,
now we flying with doves ♪
-♪ Wassup ♪
-♪ Brrr ♪
♪ These people jump off
the porch ♪
♪ Run into us and jump back
on the patio ♪
♪ Rappin like this,
finna cop me a Porsche ♪
♪ Oh, that's you chick?
I left that on the patio ♪
♪ All my brothers endorsed
of course by God ♪
♪ With principles thick
as Ray Dalio ♪
♪ When I rap gotta snap like
the back of a 70 ♪
♪ Whose pimp name was Daddio ♪
♪ It's a reason my joy slap ♪
♪ We just made a new hit,
you ain't hit back ♪
♪ None you people equipped
for the mix-match ♪
♪ Gotta know with the flow,
I could switch that ♪
♪ They finessing you brothers,
I'm 'bout mine ♪
♪ Thought my watches was broken,
it's 'bout time ♪
♪ Had to slide from the west to
south side ♪
♪ Then come back and attack
from the outside ♪
♪ With my brothas cuz they offer
poison and power ♪
♪ They offer Gucci and fame ♪
-♪ Legacy ♪
-♪ Baby, I'm new to this money ♪
♪ Baby, I'm new to this game ♪
-♪ Legacy ♪
-♪ They wanna see us in whips ♪
♪ They wanna see us in chains ♪
♪ Legacy, legacy, legacy ♪
♪ They tryna ruin the name ♪
♪ Coast ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]